Yeah. And so now he's, uh, he's
in, uh, uh, an Alzheimer's home.
But, but uh, yeah, that's the part
about is it scary about turning 50?
But he's like in,
they're nailing all these chicks we call,
we will go in there and he's like making
out with some girl with a nasal cannula
on and carrying her oxygen bottle and
he's convinced that they've been married
for a few
dead.
I have a bit in my act about the
outbreak of STDs in nursing homes.
It's out of control. Viagara oh, it's
not only just that, these people, I mean,
I mean my dad has really
advanced Alzheimer's, um,
and he knows that he misses his Mustang.
Uh, I took all this bicycles
away and I need to get laid.
That's it. I mean, and he's in
there just running around with it.
If we got called to my sister and I
take care of my dad in that manner.
And so we get called to the, uh, home,
almost like being called to the
principal's office as a, as a parent.
And they're like, your dad's
literally in here. Fucking everybody.
Like,
yeah. Literally had the feeling
of getting janked in there to the,
to the principal's office.
Like your kids a fuck up.
Your Dad's fucking every but
yeah, it'd be proud. Oh heck yeah.
What does he care? What do
you all care? That's my point.
That's what I say about him
in my acts. Like, come on man.
How do you want these people
die out? What? Their heart
to stop with the playing.
Bingo. Yeah. Yeah. Have a good time.
Just don't want him hurt each
other. We'll see. I mean the,
I'm in the healthcare business also
home health care and so I know, yeah,
I've got a lot of different ventures.
But what do you in,
how are you in the home health
care? Home health care with,
uh, with, uh, my wife, uh,
we 16, 17 years, um, maybe longer. Uh,
so in the state of Texas it's probably
the second or third largest home health
care, but I'm talking real home
healthcare. Like you've got to get shots,
you've got to get therapy.
You got,
these are Aryans that are going in and
they're not, so you go into bathe grandma,
what is your business?
So you hire a bunch of nurses to take
care of the people that are at home. Yeah,
it's prescribed,
uh,
like through Medicare or insurance or
whatever to where maybe somebody gets a
knee or a shoulder replacement or maybe
it's an injury or cancer or what have
you.
And so it's a very rewarding business.
We probably have 3000 to 2,500,
3000 patients at any given time all
around the state of Texas. And uh,
so it's, uh, it's,
it's a fun business to be and that
you're really getting help people,
but at the same time, this shit
out there crazy. These guys are,
they're getting after it.
You go into the nursing home and it's
like Dan do this 78 year old Jews had more
ass than I had
last week.
Well, you don't have anything else to do.
Nothing. Yeah. Why not? Why not? Why not?
My thought is why not? Well, I bought
my dad, uh, you know, he's got his room.
That's kind of like an
apartment or whatever.
And I bought him strip stripper sheets,
or not stripper sheets, but uh, uh, uh,
twister, twister sheets with the all
the bread and polluted peak times.
And I hung a board thing up
behind his bed. I'm like, Dad,
if you're getting after
you might as well have fun.
I mean fuck Bingo or freaking whatever.
So when, because he has Alzheimer's,
does he remember when he gets after it?
I think it's cities just so focused on,
and he says he was the, what would you
call him? A Casa Nueva or he was, he,
my dad got some serious ass my whole
life as a teenager. I was like,
God Dang it.
My Dad's like banging everything and
tense when your wife leaves you with kids,
when you're young, you just realize,
okay, I forgot about this longterm shit.
Yeah, let's just enjoy the
moment. Yeah. But I mean,
my dad was straight up products of the
sixties and seventies, you know, so he,
he like put dye his hair blonde and his
eyebrows blonde and shit and walk around,
look at like Matthew mcconaughey from
dazed and confused. All right. All right.
All right. Try driving his Mustang. You
know, he'd come pick me up from school.
What kind of Mustang did you
have back then? It was like
a 72 fast back, you know,
red and black with a four speed and he'd
be hammering it and I'm like, you know,
five,
six years old at the age I'd fall on
the floor because nobody wore a freaking
seatbelt back then.
And uh,
his idea of after school care was the
skating rink because he knew that thing.
It'd be open till nine.
So drop us off.
I'm at the skating rink eating
99 cent corn dog meal and uh,
he'd come pick us up usually around 10
or 11 with some irate skating rink owners
sitting there pissed off. And he
said, wow, he was a bad ass though.
Or is a bad ass still? I mean, he's
nailing chicks in a freaking nursing home.
Come on.
It's so weird when you become an adult,
isn't it? Oh yeah. You know,
when you think about [inaudible]
round for what we're doing,
we've got a drink wine from Arabian
Rawlings for sure. Raymond Rawlings,
Raymond Miller, Rawlings, that
his mother fucker that ever lived.
So I loop for sure.
I mean, I guarantee you he got more
acid than you and I did this whole week.
I believe it. He's freaking
probably banging one right
now. Yeah. It's like, hey,
what's that noise in the back?
Sounds like my son is the youngest
team plus the goal. The goal is like,
or the bonus rather is that they can't
get pregnant. You got that? Yeah.
I mean it's over. Yeah. Well I mean
that's a, that's not happening,
but you can still get some diseases
and stuff. Yes they do. Yes they do.
But the thing is where are
they getting them? Well,
somebody had it and then
the next thing you know,
all a hundred people in that
building have done it right.
But did they have it already or do
they getting it from the building now?
They had it already.
He had it already.
So you're dealing with herpes or you're
dealing with like the real weird ones
like syphilis and gonorrhea and shit
and syphilis and gonorrhea is like, hey,
you got to treat this. Where
are you getting this? Oh No,
it's, it's, it's prevalent.
It's everything. Right.
But the question is like,
are they getting it from outside sources?
Maybe. Maybe. I mean, who knows yet that,
that, that uh, unfortunately
that just had the baby, you know,
that it's been invalid for a 20
something years. That's crazy.
Yeah.
Somebody,
somebody knocked her F and I'm like
2007 2011 chlamydia infections amongst
Americans 65 and over increased
by 31% and syphilis by 52% yeah,
but that, the problem with
that is 52% all right. Okay.
Let's say there's a hundred cases and
then the next year there's 150 all right.
That's 52% no big,
tens of hundreds of millions of people.
My Dad's probably in there going,
come on baby.
I'm going to buy some
preliminary ideas though.
I don't like the number of
percent because if there's,
there's four people and then
the next year there's six,
that's 50% increase and I'm saying I
don't like numbers like that because you
could make, oh my God, it's
an epidemic I want, I want,
I want numbers like human beings. Yeah.
Well I'm sure it's out there on the web,
but like I said, my dad's probably thinks
chlamydia is a flower. He's given us.
He's given this girl.
I'm going to get you some chlamydia is
and we're going to have a good time. Yeah.
There's no condoms in nursing homes.
You know we got,
we got a worse 3000 reported
cases of chlamydia among
people. 45 and older. Okay,
but I'm 45 and older.
That's normal.
45 and older people are walking around
meeting New People with 43,000 seems like
a very low number. Super
Low. That's what I'm saying.
That's why I don't like
these percentage numbers.
Gonorrhea had seat from doing this
podcast all these years. I've,
I understand when people can make things
seem greater than they really are.
Go back to that. Jamie, do you have a our
P card? No, but someone set one to us,
to me and Ari.
Ari to the comedy store,
but I think that was just some asshole
who tried to thousand sounds low. Yeah.
Primary and secondary syphilis 5,650
cases were reported in this age group,
but that is 45 the thing about 45 and
older is 45 year old people in 2019 it's
not like 45 year old people
in the 60s absolutely.
These animals are out there
fucking hitting the gym
and doing squats and flying
to Thailand. They're probably getting
it from the sweat on the gym bench.